i'd like to discuss the number one sign
or symptom
that could occur
if you have overdosed on your vitamin d
but before i get into this i just have
to say something
the
danger or the side effects of not having
enough vitamin d
are about a thousand times more than
having toxicity or too much vitamin d so
that being said it's very difficult to
overdose with vitamin d let me just jump
right in i have this chart right here
and it's not scaled perfectly but it'll
give you
the rough idea of what this means so
down here we have weeks we have one week
three weeks 10 weeks 30 weeks and 100
weeks okay
now how many weeks are in a year
52 right so that's going to be somewhere
in here so you can see it's not scaled
correctly
now on the left side of this graph you
have international units of vitamin d so
up here at the top we have a million
international units and we have 300 000
international units we have 100 000 30
000 10 000 now right now you might be
taking i don't know 600 i use or a
thousand i use or maybe 2 000 i use of
your vitamin d it's like not even on
this chart
this starts at 10 000 i used and
this is what i recommend even as a
maintenance dosage so you can see even
at 10 000 i use
100 weeks
there's no toxicity at all
when we get to 30 000 okay all the way
to here maybe
up to like maybe 10 weeks
there could be some potential side
effects right 10 weeks and then we have
a hundred thousand right for maybe two
and a half weeks
it's fine
even 300 000 units for a week is fine
but there's this little section which
i'm going to explain right here
this area right here is safe if you
adjust the cofactors now what does that
mean cofactors it means that vitamin d
always works with other factors
that help it in its function and
absorption
etc
and there's two really big cofactors
magnesium
and vitamin k2
and there's other ones too like zinc and
maybe b6
that help to keep it safer and keep it
from becoming toxic for example if you
take a lot of vitamin d it helps you
absorb calcium into the blood by 20
times because that's what it does and
now you have all this extra
calcium in the blood well vitamin k2
will take it from the blood
and transport it into the bone so having
enough k2 with d3
buffers it and keeps it from creating a
problem and so this section right here
is safe if you adjust the cofactors and
also
if you drink more water because the big
problem with too much calcium is kidney
stones that's one of the symptoms it's
not the top one it's number two which
i'll get to but if you drink enough
water like two and a half liters of
fluid the odds of you getting
kidney stones go down to zero
why because kidney stones occur when you
have a super concentrated amount of
calcium
and if you're drinking enough water
there's no way the calcium can be super
concentrated anymore
so you can actually prevent that problem
but typically the toxicity effect from
vitamin d really occurs when you're
taking hundreds of thousands of
international units of vitamin d for
many many weeks okay
now that being said the number one
sign would be calcification somewhere in
your body now what's common for women is
calcification
in the breast tissue right that's kind
of a benign situation it doesn't create
any problems but it can occur you can
have calcification in any organ or
tissue so that would be the first
sign that you have too much vitamin d
number two kidney stones okay but of
course kidney stones could come from
many different things
number three nerve symptoms like
numbness
pain
tingling any type of weird type symptoms
with your nerves that could be
a sign that you have too much vitamin d
and number four is excessive thirst okay
and number five excessive urination both
of these now what's interesting about
these two is you usually get these
symptoms when you're a diabetic but in
this situation it's where you have too
much calcium because the vitamin d is
too high so there you have it these are
the symptoms but i want to show you
something
that relates to toxicity i think this is
my theory
i think
um a lot of the cases that you hear
about with toxicity are from vitamin d2
not vitamin d3 you see
the doctors usually prescribe vitamin d2
not d3 okay they'll usually give you
like 50 000 international units of
vitamin d2 once a week
and there's some really big differences
between vitamin d2 and d3 that i'm going
to explain that could cause the person
to take vitamin d2 for a long period of
time simply because they're not going to
really see the results okay
let me explain let's compare d2
to d3
well first of all d2 is not as effective
as d3 it's not as bioavailable
is not as studied
it does not prevent fractures like
vitamin d3 will but it does reverse
rickets in infants which is a severe
vitamin d deficiency it has a different
effect on the symptom depression which
relates to a couple factors which i
don't want to necessarily get into in
this video and this next one is very
important to know it does not affect
the immune system okay it doesn't
improve the immune system like vitamin
d3 so here you are taking the two
and not seeing the results so maybe
you'll be taking more or for a long
period of time and that potentially
could be and this is just my theory why
there is toxicity in the first place but
again i'm not 100 on that but that's
just my theory now since we talked about
the main symptom which is calcification
which is excess calcium i think it's
very appropriate to watch this video
next right here